[Musique]
Oh
pour
avec peu de pluie
tout le mois de janvier parce qu'il a baissé
tout à fait le niveau
[Musique]
c'est impressionnant de le voir comme ça
ce que ce que nous allons rarement
pour pouvoir à nouveau profiter de ce paysage
et c'est pourquoi nous nous sommes approchés pour prendre des photos
et qu'au moins nous avons la photo de
qu'est-ce qu'un jour était-ce
utilisé pour venir travailler ici à pied
d'un pion de maçon bien sûr
et bon de le voir alors de le voir maintenant
[Musique]
C'était un sentiment que c'est ce que nous allons
avoir il semble que les années avec le
la sécheresse et tout ça on ne trouvera pas
[Musique]